[Music]
in unusual robbery news submitted by a
West Coast West Coast the man's cousin
tried to rob him at gunpoint for some of
the most ridiculous household items Wow
cuts in you're gonna take my shaving
cream cousin that's stupid eyes this one
is so [ __ ] funny this one I was bad
acid I was cracking up and beat rhinos
cuz he helps me out too you saw all
right can we guess the household end
today we're building up I know if not
better be funny be funny if I'm not
laughing then it's not this guy's been
like you'll give me your dildos dude
give me those [ __ ] big one no get the
big one please the rubber fist still
makes sense though what if it's like
lime paper yeah right
oh that's true that's pretty good
customer [ __ ] I need some oil supplies
like a cup of sugar so you got three
more punch sugar cookie sheet and it's
because the cousin who got his item
stolen like his interview is [ __ ]
funny so I'm just gonna pause it's not
the items that are funny the items are
pretty funny but it's all funny
apparently we'll be the judge there's a
guy funny-looking do have a funny phone
number this takes place in Kentucky okay
that's what Fried Chicken comes from
here we go
must've been a bad batch around here
these were crazy in the last four days
neighbors notified all right how he
opens his mouth he's beaten his house
finally got the house look see what
happened the door was standing wide open
it looked like he was packing up for
yard sale when he came out he was lying
on his hands saying stuff like dude you
know how rogues do is blaming on
everybody else he did pull a gun on me
when I got back around the house because
I guess he thought I was upset with him
who steals a cheese great
most it was him stealing myself is this
real oh that's like the most 20s other
twin I've ever heard it's pretty deep so
please Bayou Boutte spins us to taste
wine Wow is this how it is on TV in the
south is it just like redneck TV I guess
so I feel like if you're watching local
news is it like look weather day looking
pretty [ __ ] hard up like is it like
is it like that does anybody know I'll
be [ __ ] dope if it was I would just
move there just like a watch TV all day
even the car commercials is like are you
in an accident and you need help
you think so it's causing yeah I don't
know that I can't do it with the
announcer you just said it completely
normally you said it slowly yeah anyway
this entire video was [ __ ] dying
so anyway this meth head cousin he went
to his cousin's house and I started
stealing all these random things why
would you go to your biggest cousin's
house to steal things
I know coli so just it looks like it
would just sit on him and kill him but
he had to cause frail-looking like a
[ __ ] but he gotta go now
he did have a gun
that equalizes the situation wait so so
he pulled the gun out on them and then
what happened like he how did he catch
him or like let him like I was just too
into the cheese grater
I know same no but yeah yeah I don't
think I understood anything
so he's a meth head he's a meth head oh
so he's feeling a little pawn shop with
this stuff right maybe a meth head yard
sale yeah yeah cuz apparently a lot of
people in that county have been just
acting really crazy for they like but
those last few days and so it's cousins
a little bit of crack in that meth those
items all make any sense
Hey empty bottle of life oh I need this
I want to see him like going through the
house figuring out like do I need a
peach no doom I need one maybe a little
bit I do need this bottle lid because I
know personally speaking you can fill up
like a bottle like an empty bottle of
soap you swish it around a little bit
and then you got like soap for like nine
more days it's like a bottle he picked
out the same [ __ ] Tyco might have picked
up well Tyco is just a little kid like
baby mode where they're just trying to
kill themselves all day yeah yeah that's
right
pick stuff up and put it in his mouth
right so that's what methods doing so
this is what he was gonna do with it
so he was first using the Lysol to wash
his bathtub and shower and then he's
gonna take a shower with the soap and
after he gets out he was gonna grate
some cheese and make some pizza yeah
he's just trying to clean his meth house
up and everyone's making fun of them
it's a great little brie cheese because
when you're on math you'd think you can
grate brie cheese you really can't so
you should know that it's really frowned
upon it's so met decisions are so funny
man like I remember my buddy was so
[ __ ] tweaked out he rearranged his
desk like three times within 30 minutes
just just like non-stop and then he was
like all right and then he would go back
all right no and then I'm like what the
[ __ ] it was just crazy watching him
tweaked out maybe he goes math because
because she's constantly rearrange she's
always at I come home and she changed
the whole section of things and
rearranged the desk is always moving
like grape all the time is that a bad
thing
no I'm saying she doesn't remember
because you rearranges it all right yeah
yeah yeah no she loses all all things at
all time and she and then she gets
really angry but why she always
reorganizing if she's losing [ __ ] all
the time I don't know and then she and
then she gets really angry when she's
looking for somebody she's like have you
seen my beach bag she's like I just saw
it I had just had it in my hand I
understand and she actually get all the
way into a wormhole so she like she's
like I just had it in my hip I just had
no universe they look at just like let
it go and find it happens when she finds
it and like the most obvious place she
gets frustrated and almost starts to cry
because it's never the place that you
think you had it it's always the last
place right like that's the dad joke but
but it's um no it's like a she really
does think that there's somebody [ __ ]
with her no that's a good that we could
one advice constantly taking her stuff
and hiding it
but I have to deal with it like if I
didn't have to deal with it this hard if
it was funnier during the export of the
part while she's looking for [ __ ] I
would do it all the time but it's not at
all funny when she's looking for [ __ ]
and like when she's looking for [ __ ]
it's like she's look it's like it's like
she lost a new baby in the house is on
fire like it's like that the whole
[ __ ] time I'm like what like oh my
god this is but I'm like I don't see a
fire and I know that that's not a baby
so who cares maybe you're taking it that
way but she's just emotionally just like
more passionate about explaining it and
you're thinking it's but inside she's
probably like oh man I can't believe I
lost again it's not that big of a Maya
therapy with you jihad Jesus Wow no it
might am i reaching you right now are
you yeah maybe you're just kind of
making it seem like she's all
exaggerated when she's really not you
can happy what I'm doing is I'm
trivializing the situation I think
you're reaching her because we had the
same dynamic
like she she like crazy and for me also
feels like a burning house what the [ __ ]
and then later on I find out that it's
actually nothing but a job way that she
expressed I'm right there with you that
[ __ ] gets me [ __ ] PTSD I'm like holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
enemies or something and it's like nods
nothing and I'm like okay oh [ __ ] man I
almost [ __ ] had a heart attack
recently Casey took off his wedding ring
to do like oh no yeah he's actually a
living [ __ ] up already
and when I got home I saw it on the
counter and so I grabbed and I put it on
my fingers and so I had it evil all day
the whole [ __ ] day I didn't even
notice
not once yeah towards the end of the
night we were ready getting ready to bed
getting ready to go to bed and he was
like oh my god
where's my ring where'd I leave my ring
you like in your leg the whole live
wouldn't you like to know right here and
then I actually switched it around like
this were like I don't okay I don't know
and then Isaac was there cuz we're
watching a movie he turns around he was
like he immediately thought in all this
like last time we just kept seeing him
like going crazy all over the house like
like moving things you're just going and
then like the longer we waited panicked
he got it was so funny
finally I went up to him I'm like I
don't know honey like where did we leave
him oh my god he was like oh my god you
had it and I was just like Doug or psy
had it the whole time I got home this
was I got home like midday it was
already like already nighttime so I was
just like dude the whole day I had it I
had it on my fingers I kept doing this
in front of you you never saw it
I took a joke too far too far I loved
seeing him panic cause I'm like oh my
god you have like a routine a check like
a check keys wallet phone thing I do
that so the other day I made myself
panic because I was on my phone right
and I was about to leave the house so I
did my [ __ ] check check and I was
like where's my [ __ ] phone and I'm
like looking at Twitter and I'm like
[ __ ]
I'm pulling the phone and I'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay let me check my Jeebs maybe
somebody knows my fart it's not in my
pocket you know I'm doing the check
check check and I'm like damn it was
like damn that was so stupid
that happens to me sometimes right well
whatever I'm looking for it in my hand
like the key that well [ __ ] are the key
you they're just making all these noise
but there's just in my hand all I was
looking for my foot to use a flashlight
with my grandpa was alive and kicking he
would always lose [ __ ] and he would
always yell at my grandma about it and
he would always she would always know
where exactly where it was but it was
always exactly where it belonged
Brina where the absolute living Jesus
raised in a car seat in a hot summer day
is the [ __ ] remote to the television
and she's like it's the same goddamn
place is bad for 35 years dick it's in
the [ __ ] TV stand and he'd be like
are you [ __ ] yeah so you would just
forget did you just tell them if they
would forget where the things belong and
then he would get so angry because we
all react to everything the show I would
watch oh the way that he could say Jesus
Christ's name was always inventive and
like extremely creative that was my dad
way sister mother like like iko iko like
the mother he would say that but then he
would add a bunch of other [ __ ]
peachy male like you're like yeah I know
I mean that's like some rapper [ __ ] like
it was even more fun
you know I was like what the name of the
Jesus who was nailed up on the cross
nails like that were like oh my god
left to right up guilty yeah
[Music]
[Music]